but I think Logan needs to take a 90-day
break and step away from everybody
say go on a 90-day hiatus hiatus from
wrestling from everything you you are a
rock star the world knows who you are
step away and go back and write down
make a list of values and principles
that you follow that you live by go and
remember the 12 year old kid you were
things your mom's taught you mistakes
you've made how you've learned from them
don't don't come back with a script that
your publicist has given you to tell the
world speak to certain people that don't
benefit from you that don't make money
off of you that wants nothing from you
and see if they can give you some
direction on how to approach this
because this is not going in the right
direction the way things are going